说话人 1: 哈喽，你好，我是Jackson，欢迎来到我们第二部分的关系升级聊天记录的讲解
说话人 1: 第一部分我们讲了怎么去破解女生废测面具，还有她的框架，把女生给约出来
说话人 1: OK，当时学员把这个女生约出来之后，是逐一做了一些升级，OK，女生是长期没有能收尾，联系感做了一些，吸引力是有下降的，在我们后面的聊天体现的到，这个时候我们去做了很多的东西去逆转，这里给大家详细的去展示一下
说话人 1: OK，废话不多说，咱们直接开始
说话人 1: 女生她发了一个表情包，她说你叫我爸爸
说话人 1: 这是在第二天醒了之后，女生白天给他发的
说话人 1: 我们看到这样的一个信号，我们直接植入性话题，但是程度没有那么高
说话人 1: 我就发了一个，我说不，我铁S
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是只有 M 才会叫爸爸，对吧
说话人 1: 我说我是S，就不会叫
说话人 1: 同时又植入了一个性话题，让女生去往这方面的思维去拉
说话人 1: 女生，对吧
说话人 1: 窗口还是有，她跟你玩起来了，她说铁骚，我懂了
说话人 1: 就是她去误解你这样的话，同时跟你进入一个flow
说话人 1: 我说是好还是坏
说话人 1: 就是我说骚这一点是好还是坏
说话人 1: 让女生来进行一个短择和长择的一个选择，女生说好也不好，OK，很模糊很中性的一个回答，我要去把它确实的去体现出来，我还会去追加，我说好占比多少
说话人 1: 坏占比多少
说话人 1: 女生说好30%，坏70%，这个时候她给出了她的属性，就是偏长期，对吧
说话人 1: 当然这个时候我们不能全信，我们还要去继续试探，这时候我说跟你的长相不符，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是她的外表打扮非常的骚，对吧
说话人 1: 穿黑丝，搞那些很骚的一些东西，看起来就很骚
说话人 1: 她说她自己是长期，这个时候我就会说，OK，跟你的打扮跟你的什么不符合，对吧
说话人 1: 她明显是
说话人 1: 不太匹配的，这个时候我要去怀疑他，看他会怎么样的解释
说话人 1: 他说什么
说话人 1: 我说的不是我
说话人 1: OK，他其实没懂我的意思，因为喜欢骚的男生，女生都会很，都会比较短期
说话人 1: 我说你看起来不像没安全感的类型啊，这个时候我明显把这个东西给他剖析出来
说话人 1: 他说女孩子都没安全感，发了一个表情
说话人 1: 这非常的打太极，他这个回答非常的打太极
说话人 1: 我去怎么样做这个东西
说话人 1: 我说跟我相处胆子可以大一点，毕竟你是要保护我的
说话人 1: OK，这是上了一个框架，同时还在鼓励他往短期去发展
说话人 1: 就放开她自己，不要那么女权，不要那么女本位，对吧
说话人 1: 她说你给我付工资，就把她请来当保镖
说话人 1: 这个时候我不会给她投资，我反而会跟她battle，我说两个大逼兜不能再多了，这是在她脑子里形成一个画面，就是我不是那种很好惹的人
说话人 1: 她说我返你一倍，当时这个聊天已经没有张力了，对吧
说话人 1: 再聊下去就成了，就偏题了
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员去抽离，对吧
说话人 1: 我们来进行一个长线的联系感疗法
说话人 1: 到了第二天的下午，我让学员给她开一个场，我说屁股晒太阳了，这也是做了一个话术的一个反差，明明是太阳晒屁股了，对吧
说话人 1: 我要说屁股晒太阳了
说话人 1: 去尝试做一个情绪的一个东西
说话人 1: 女生说没下雨
说话人 1: 我说你想它下吗
说话人 1: 我们在暗示什么
说话人 1: 就是你想它下吗
说话人 1: 下了的话我们就见不着了，就是这样的一个意思
说话人 1: 女生她说下雨世界会安静一些，对吧
说话人 1: 她其实可能她的内心是比较渴望一些长期的，渴望一些很安宁的一些生活，这可以肯定出她是一个比较长期的女生
说话人 1: 我说这不像你，对吧
说话人 1: 我还是在复格她的短期，想让她把短期尽量的榨取出来，尽量多的一些短期，不是说让她 100% 的短期，尽量多一点短期，这会有助于我们去收尾，知道吧
说话人 1: 这会更加的合理化我们的收尾行为
说话人 1: 他发了这个学员当时的足浴的偷拍的一些照片
说话人 1: 这个时候我说，成了我的脑残粉吗
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 他把我当成一个明星去偷拍了，这样的一个感觉
说话人 1: 女生说什么
说话人 1: 你什么意思啊
说话人 1: 这个时候，对吧
说话人 1: 女生很笨，我们就要把这个东西给延续上
说话人 1: 我会，我的聊天方式会在前面埋一个雷
说话人 1: 如果说女生不懂这个雷，那么我会把这个雷给她引爆，让她知道这个雷是什么样的一个性质
说话人 1: 我说你偷拍你的偶像大佬
说话人 1: 她说我胆子小，你下播我就跑了
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 女生其实框架又倍感住了，其实窗口又慢慢的开始浮现了，我们就要去把这个窗口撕大，给它升级
说话人 1: 我说那你以后怎么保护我
说话人 1: 还是在上一个高位框架，对吧
说话人 1: 上一个奖品框架
说话人 1: 她说什么呀
说话人 1: 凭什么你给你买个乌龟壳吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我说你能不能怜香惜玉一点
说话人 1: 还是在维持我们的奖品框架，对吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看到，这其实是非常调情，非常打情骂俏的一种感觉，这种感觉能在女生脑子里留下印象，懂不懂
说话人 1: 我们要去创造这样的感觉，特别是在线上的关系维护、关系升级之中
说话人 1: 女生回了一个啊，我其实当时是不想聊了，我让这个学员抽离了
说话人 1: 到了第二天，我们又去进行一个开场
说话人 1: 去进行一个邀约，我说我想吃海底捞，你陪我
说话人 1: 这里其实用到一个技巧，我想请你吃海底捞，这会非常beta，对吧
说话人 1: 你请女生还要去请求，这很
说话人 1: 我们更多的一个逻辑就是，我们去玩某种东西，我们去体验某种东西，让女生来陪我们
说话人 1: 能进行，知道吗
说话人 1: 他是一个附属的一个角色，我们要去这样的形容，所以说我会在这里说，我想去吃海底捞，你陪我一起，要给出这样的命令式的一些回答
说话人 1: 女生很简单就复格了，对吧
说话人 1: 她说好的，老爷
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们再继续索要投资，我说行个礼再退下
说话人 1: 女生她没接这样的一个东西，对吧
说话人 1: 她可能也想维持她的框架，但是不重要，我们会缓慢的击碎她的框架
说话人 1: 到了下午，女生又说下雨了，这个时候我回的一个东西是强化她的脑子里的一个逻辑，强化她脑子里的之前的一个印象，就是我们最开始约的时候就是在下雨，所以说我在这里回的是，每次下雨我都想到你
说话人 1: 女生也进入了你的一个调情环境，她说，那你不是天天都要想到我
说话人 1: 这个时候我把我的投资拉回来一点，我说我有在克制，毕竟女人带毒，对吧
说话人 1: 女生说出了一个很重要的点，她说我也在克制，毕竟我容易上头
说话人 1: 你们可以看出这个女生她是想要的，但是她在，对吧
说话人 1: 她在克制自己，她很谨慎，她怕自己上头，她怕自己陷入进去，这个东西需要去知道，需要去把这个点给记住
说话人 1: 这个时候我给出了一个看似是失格，但是我能圆回来的一个话术，我说那我们岂不是在浪费时间成本
说话人 1: 女生听到这句话的第一时间可能以为我在推开她，对吧
说话人 1: 可能以为我在推开她，就是我觉得我们这样是在浪费时间，对吧
说话人 1: 会让她觉得这样
说话人 1: 这个时候当人在失格的时候，当人在自我失格的时候，对方就很容易舔上来，对方就很容易去复格，这个是一种生理本能，因为对自己投资的东西快要失去的那种感觉，就本能的想要去追大投资，把这个东西给拉回来
说话人 1: 然后女生说有浪费吗
说话人 1: 那好好珍惜
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 他其实是在有勾魂的一些操作了，这个时候我要把这个能量给拉回来，我说我的意思是何不去冲动一把，不应该那么累，对吧
说话人 1: 我们不要扯淡，我们就想爱就爱，对吧
说话人 1: 给他鼓励这样的一个行为
说话人 1: OK，然后女生心里是知道了这个东西，她只是没有回应，但我知道她已经听懂了我的意思，就我们接下来的进度要加快
说话人 1: 然后她说好困，又下雨，到时间想我了，就很扯淡，她已经开始去进入这样的一个氛围了，只是她想去多拉一些你的投资，知道吗
说话人 1: 女生是想多拉一些你的投资，但已经到了暧昧的一些氛围了
说话人 1: 然后这个学员当时他们的发烧了，对吧
说话人 1: 身体不争气，本来是可以
说话人 1: 当天是已经约出来了，本来当天是可以约出来的，但是他自己身体搞砸了，就只能我们下次去约，这个时候只能在线上去做一些升级，所以说我就帮他调整了策略，去线上做一些很深度的一些升级，而不是靠线下
说话人 1: 女生说高烧是真的假的
说话人 1: 她说是不是逃单
说话人 1: 你想他们的不想请我吃饭了，对吧
说话人 1: 是这样的一个意思
说话人 1: 这个时候我回答了她这样的一个问题，我说我想要你的爱，不必找这种烂借口，表面上是要她的爱，对吧
说话人 1: 不是欺骗她，不是发烧，实际上是说我不请你吃饭
说话人 1: 我不带你去吃这个海底捞，是因为我身体出毛病了，对吧
说话人 1: 当时是不能约的
说话人 1: 这个女生她说你跟谁去淋雨了，对吧
说话人 1: 她故意这样搞，我们直接无视掉，我说你这叫延迟性收尾，这里也是在玩啊，用了一些 game 术语，用了我一些我自己体系的一些术语，然后去逗一下女生
说话人 1: 女生说，是吗
说话人 1: 那我怎么做老板
说话人 1: 我说你来陪我，这里做了一个未来画面，就是她在我的房间，她在我的家里面，对吧
说话人 1: 她来陪我那样的一些画面
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说什么陪啊
说话人 1: 我说陪我度过这场灾难，你不心疼吗
说话人 1: 就她的脑子里可能在想一些很瑟琴的东西，对吧
说话人 1: 可能要被我收尾
说话人 1: 但是我更多的还是往深度复格，更多的去往深度的一些吸引去做，因为哪怕这个女生来到这个学员家里，她也不能，对吧
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说要多久你才好
说话人 1: 然后我让她回答重点，心不心疼
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说，她说勾引我，然后引导我表白吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你想一下，还引导你表白，那就证明，就说出这样的话的人，自己已经都默认喜欢了这个人，知道吗
说话人 1: 她就已经展示出这种破绽了，这个时候我敏锐的察觉到这样的东西，我说我都知道，不用你表白，就是我已经知道她心里想什么了，因为她体现出的一些情况，体现出的一些状态
说话人 1: 然后这个女生她在疯狂的解释，她发了一个表情，她说你滚啊，懂不懂
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个嗅觉非常的重要，我已经知道了，这个女生已经彻底的被学员给干住了，然后我说接受她
说话人 1: 这个女生说接受什么
说话人 1: 我继续鼓励她，我说接受你内心的魔鬼
说话人 1: 什么
说话人 1: 让她接受她喜欢我的这个事实
说话人 1: 女生她知道了我的意思，但是她只是想要扯淡，OK，我们知道
说话人 1: 我们继续开撩，用一些可能土味情话，用一些什么
说话人 1: 但这个时候我告诉兄弟们，土味情话在什么时候可以用
说话人 1: 就是在你跟这个女生的阶段非常深入的时候，你用这些土味情话，它才能调情，它是有非常好的一些作用，但是在前期不要去用，知道吗
说话人 1: 这个女生说她说我是小三，可以看到这个女生非常的谨慎，非常的安全感，非常的差，她又喜欢去，对吧
说话人 1: 去臆测别人，所以说是非常凶险的跟这种女人接触，你错了一步，她就会说
说话人 1: 把他的头给缩进去，我说嘴里缺甜，应该找我借一点
说话人 1: 他说这不是你喜欢的吗
说话人 1: 我说把我的借过去再还给我，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是OK，你来亲我，就我的嘴甜，你来亲我，我再还给你，我来亲你，知道吗
说话人 1: 是这样的一个画面感，只是用了一个艺术性的表达方式在女生的脑子里
说话人 1: 女生说，OK，可以看到她认为我们是要猥琐她，是要怎么
说话人 1: 然后他自己又给自己上框架，但是他接受了这样的一个未来画面
说话人 1: 然后这个时候我们做了一个操作，就是给他上一个框架
说话人 1: 为什么要在这里给他上框架
说话人 1: 因为如果说他骂你骂成惯性了，他或者说搞你搞成惯性了，你在以后非常难搞定
说话人 1: 所以说我更多的是为了以后去做一些铺垫
说话人 1: 我发了一个问号，兄弟们问号这个东西威力是非常大的，它能把女生干破防，在很多时候
说话人 1: 然后你们立刻可以看到女生疯狂的解释了一大堆，她说哈哈哈，然后发了一个那种表情，想要承认错误，对吧
说话人 1: 咋了
说话人 1: 叫你
说话人 1: 她就在试探性的我是不是这里做错了
说话人 1: 然后我直接给出我的需求，我说不太喜欢这个称呼哦
说话人 1: 女生说我喜欢
说话人 1: 我说给你挂个号，他说什么号
说话人 1: 我都说我有VIP
说话人 1: 我说混账客 VIP 是吧
说话人 1: 他说我咋成混账了
说话人 1: OK，当时又是切断聊天了，因为聊后面的升级联系感是需要，不能说拉长吧，因为学员始终没法见面，要是维持联系感的话，每天或者说固定一个时间要去搞两下
说话人 1: 学员这个时候病好了，我让他去开场发最近怎么样
说话人 1: 女生说应该怎么样
说话人 1: 你恢复的怎么样
说话人 1: 可以肉眼的看出女生的需求感是非常强的
说话人 1: 我又跟她做了一个深度的沟通，我说应该怎么样
说话人 1: 你过得怎么样
说话人 1: 女生说不太好，心情不太好
说话人 1: 我说不打算主动坦白吗
说话人 1: 女生说什么
说话人 1: 她有点，对吧
说话人 1: 不知道应该怎么回答我这样的一个回答
说话人 1: 我们要看这个行为，就是你在什么情况下你会不太好，不太敢去回答，不太敢怎么样
说话人 1: 这种行为就体现了你是一个选择者，你的框架很高
说话人 1: 这里我说让你心情不好的坏遭遇
说话人 1: OK，女生这里就开始解释了，她说坦白，我以为我做错事了，对吧
说话人 1: 你觉得一个喜欢你的女生，她只有在这种情况，她才会说，哦，我做错事了，想要害怕自己说出来什么东西，对不对
说话人 1: 你们要观察到这样的一个情况
说话人 1: 我说错在不跟我分享
说话人 1: 这个时候女生都，对吧
说话人 1: 有怨言出来了，这是代表什么
说话人 1: 这是代表她想要你的一些联系感
说话人 1: 她说
说话人 1: 你都不理我，看起来很埋怨，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我给出了一个很重要的点，我说你看起来不是很想要，我的意思是你不要再装逼了，喜欢就喜欢，对吧
说话人 1: 喜欢就主动一点，我们要以这个尺子来测量这个关系的一个深度
说话人 1: 女生说了一个很重要的一个信息，她说没有，她想要，其实，对吧
说话人 1: 她想要
说话人 1: 这个时候我给出了我自己的一个奖励，我说发烧有在想你，因为她有想我，对吧
说话人 1: 她因为她想要，所以说我也说我发烧有在想你
说话人 1: 这个女生很开心，她说现在不想了，过去了
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员说我病好了，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是我可以约了，我们可以见了
说话人 1: 我只发一个这样的东西，女生是绝对能听懂的
说话人 1: 女生说能吃火锅了吗
说话人 1: 我想吃
说话人 1: 我说哪天
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看到女生这个时候的购买度很夸张啊，你们能想到，到最开始到现在的这样的一个购买度的变化
说话人 1: 女生说哪天都行，是你就行
说话人 1: 从女生最开始高位到现在，哪天都行，是你都行
说话人 1: 像不像你去跟女人说，是你都可以，对不对
说话人 1: 这种确信感是很强的
说话人 1: 我让学员发了一个他自己的时间，就后天，对吧
说话人 1: 就开始制定时间了，后面
说话人 1: 当时跟这个女生第一次约会的时候，她淋了雨，可能之后就发烧了
说话人 1: 这里
说话人 1: 给他复习了一下当天的一个情形，对吧
说话人 1: 所以才要你的保护，重复一下当天的一个印象
说话人 1: 我说你是老虎，这是一个什么意思
说话人 1: 就是把他当成一个追求者，我们自己是奖品，重复的去强化这样的一个框架
说话人 1: 你可以看到女生完全把自己框架给丢了，她说还是母的
说话人 1: 她说明天请了假，啥意思
说话人 1: 就是明天可以约，对吧
说话人 1: 明天请了，专门请了一天假，可以玩，可以陪你
说话人 1: 这个时候我们要给出奖励，对吧
说话人 1: 多亲你一个作为奖励，持续的去对女生进行复格，在她做对的时候
说话人 1: 这个时候女生她是非常黏腻的，只是OK，有些关系没有确定，她只是会有一些怀疑
说话人 1: 但是她是非常享受这样的一个暧昧的，她说这么快就亲朋好友了，我在这里直接不要退缩，直接加强这个行为，我说那要把舌头伸进去才行吗
说话人 1: 这里搞出了一个小插曲啊，因为这个学员设置的备注就是黑丝遛狗女，我会认为这个女生是有狗的
说话人 1: 实际上搞了一个乌龙，是这个女生的朋友在遛狗，这个学员当时没给我说清楚，所以说搞出了这样一个乌龙
说话人 1: 女生的废策就来了，她说我哪来的狗子
说话人 1: 说记错了，带你去会看，带你去看会侧空翻的狗
说话人 1: 本来是想OK，靠一个话术过去，但其实这个女生她非常注重这一点，她要把这一点搞清楚
说话人 1: 她说继承谁的就带谁去吧，非常强力的一个废策，但实际上是假性的
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 她只需要你一个解释就够了
说话人 1: 这时候我们拿了一个有框架的东西去改变她，但是没有那么舔，稍微有点框架，对吧
说话人 1: 的解释说拿你朋友的狗去垫你，这个意思就是那个狗是你朋友的嘛，当时认错了是你的，但是这个女生当时是没有接，对吧
说话人 1: 想给这个学员造成一些心理障碍，心理影响
说话人 1: 到了下午，让学员去主动发一个表情试探一下情况，女生说我是狗
说话人 1: 我这里准备铺垫一个话术，我不知道她能不能听懂，我说我的酒窝没有酒，下一句就是
说话人 1: 你却醉的像条狗，我想说这样的一个东西来说他是狗的这样一个情况，但是他没有接，没有接我们就放弃掉那个话术，对吧
说话人 1: 我们开一个新的话题，女生发了一个
说话人 1: 表情，对吧
说话人 1: 因为在之前的一个情况没有解决，就是这个学员搞错了这一点，我在这里要把这个东西拿出来先解决掉，我说有啥事说，女生说，吹干头发了
说话人 1: OK，那就代表其实没事，没事了我们就继续说，心不在焉的，肚子还没饿吗
说话人 1: 女生说，辛苦你先排位置了
说话人 1: 后面就是一个调度的情况，这时候我看到女生说刚化好妆，我们瞄准这个点，让她做一些投资，我说点一颗泪痣我喜欢，就说出了自己一个独特的观察力
说话人 1: 女生说，你咋知道有
说话人 1: 就有点肿，说我挤痘嘎嘎猛
说话人 1: 这就是完整的一个线上升级的一个过程
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看到女生完全是同意男女朋友的框架了，知道吗
说话人 1: 只差出来说好这个游戏规则
说话人 1: 我说一下这个聊天的一个后续情况
说话人 1: 这个女生当时跟他吃完饭是要去他家里充电，因为女生手机没有电了
说话人 1: 当时学员很，他说他家里有人，或者说他说去家里充电干嘛
说话人 1: 他当时非常的扯淡，我后面给他复盘分析了一下，我说女生知道街边有充电宝可以充电，不需要你去提醒
说话人 1: 女生想去你家里充电，代表她想跟你有进一步接触
说话人 1: 这个学员当时很扯淡，他说家里有人就不放女生进去了，非常的遗憾
说话人 1: 但是这个收尾我觉得 100% 能搞定，只是学员有些操作出现了问题，他当时也是想OK，想发展更长期，但是我说更长期不是这样去处理的，一定要得先收尾，一定要得先收尾，你才能去
说话人 1: 当女生想要收尾的时候，你为什么不去收
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 这个后面的一些问题随之而来，这也就是聊天跟人的不匹配造成的一些一致性断裂，这个需要长久的去修炼
说话人 1: OK，兄弟们可以在这节课里面学到非常多的一些关系升级的一些女性心理也好，一些技巧也好，好好学习，我是Jackson，下期再见